okay but just do a second set of
contracts so let's kill this [ __ ] thing
as a vampire hear God's a man of a fit
of privacy yeah
dan tied death Oh
and I by myself black mascara
drink up food here
am i worth it ok I get the second
contract [ __ ]
I mean gone tomorrow yet all right I'll
just go to hear it take the stables
[Music]
there we go need a ride where do you
want to go and I think Adam miles out
back and we'll be all yeah they go for
that Jeff thank God s SE lui ok we will
believe me a little bit mmmm mmmmmm
mmmmmm penis I love me some penis penis
is good for the soul penis is God for
this house how are we supposed to be
safe now penis is good for the soul
let's give the bed for the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
oh my order of ER stop right there and
yeah cat thing I guess you're smart at
the time against all you
let's work on mate such as let's pretend
those [ __ ]
we need to talk all right look something
is happening here I'm not sure entirely
what that something is but well we need
to find out if the night mother really
did give you in order to talk to a
contact we'd be mad to ignore it and I
think we'd both agree Cicero's brought
quite enough madness to this sanctuary
so go go to volunteer it's a crypt
pretty far to the north east talk to
this amond MultiAir and let's see where
all this leads you're a lot still here
your payment moussaka and if you
contracted sanguine re-vamp yurius be
sure to get that taken care of well
she'll end up like our own Babette thank
you thanks for watching batches back
down